Hi everyone who is learning English with EnglishCentral.
My name is Fairoz.
I'm a forward for Albirex Niigata Singapore.
Today, I would like to introduce about Singapore football.
First of all, the weather.
The weather is very humid in Singapore.
It's very hot and our matches on the weekend would be 5:30 onwards.
So, on the first half, you're gonna be in hot weather.
Maybe, the second half, from 6 PM onwards,...
...it will be a nice, cooling weather, a little bit, for the weekend.
For weekdays, it's gonna be good weather; it's cooling.
It's a little bit humid, but it's gonna be a little bit hot, I should say.
So second of all, the rules and regulations for our Singapore Premier League.
First of all, most of the clubs will need under 23 below to play in a match,...
...and the rest will be overage.
So, the next one, on the third, I would like to say about the NS.
Usually, some of them having NS, some of them part-time,...
...some of them schooling, some of them working full-time.
So there's a lot of commitment outside,...
...at least, before they come for training.
Some of them can make it, some of them cannot make it for the day,...
...so the coach has to organize the training...
...and they have to text all the players whether you can make it for today's training.
Whoever comes to Singapore,...
...please come and watch the Singapore Premier League football matches.